the issue here having come out with that
kind of rhetoric on from the
presidential level raises the ante and
what we have always done in the past is
take the rhetoric emanating from North
Korea with a grain of salt and when we
take it seriously like this and and
threaten as the President did that's a
that's a pretty heavy message and when
he says speaks of the fire and fury this
is very reminiscent of the rhetoric that
North Korea uses about transforming
Seoul into a sea of fire and I believe
they would if if they were attacked with
all that artillery and rocketry that
they have lined up along the DMZ so that
fire and fury statement doesn't just
apply to North Korea because that
jeopardizes literally millions of people
in South Korea not to mention the
regional implications